ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast, where
we discuss science and science
based tools for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask
Me Anything or AMA
episode, which is part of our
premium subscriber content.
Our premium channel
was launched in order
to raise support for the
standard Huberman Lab podcast
channel, which still comes
out once a week every Monday,
and of course, is
zero cost to consumer.
The premium channel
is also designed
to support exciting
research being
done at major universities
like Stanford and elsewhere.
Research that's
done on humans that
should lead to protocols for
mental health, physical health
and performance in
the near future.
If you'd like to check out the
premium channel subscription
model, you can go to
hubermanlab.com/premium
and there you can subscribe
for $10 a month or $100 a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscriber option.
For those of you that are
already Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers and you're
watching and/or hearing this,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the
premium podcast feed.
And for those of you
that are not already
Huberman Lab Premium
podcast subscribers,
you will be able to hear
the first 15 minutes or so
of this episode
and hopefully that
will allow you to
discern whether or not
you would like to become
a premium subscriber.
Without further ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
And as always, I will strive
to be as clear as possible,
as succinct as possible, and
as thorough as possible while
still answering as many
questions per AMA episode
as I can without these sessions
becoming unreasonably long.
I should also point out
that if you asked a question
and it was not
answered this AMA,
it may very well be
answered in the next AMA.
So the first question,
which had a lot of upvotes--
meaning many people wanted
the answer to this question--
came from Jackson Lipfert.
And the question was about
so-called ultradian rhythms.
For those of you that are
not familiar with ultradian
rhythms-- ultradian
rhythms are any rhythms
that are shorter than 24 hours.
And typically when
people ask about
or talk about
ultradian rhythms, they
are referring to
90-minute rhythms.
I've talked about these
on the podcast before.
And Jackson's question was--
how do you use ultradian rhythms
in your daily work?
There's more to the
question, but first off, I
do use ultradian
rhythms-- that is,
I leverage the fact that
these do exist in all of us
as a way to engage in
focused bouts of mental work
once or twice, or sometimes
three times per day.
However, I use them
in a way that's
grounded in the research on
ultradian rhythms for learning
and memory in a
way that might not
be obvious just from
their name that they
are 90-minute rhythms.
So I'll get into the details
of how to use ultradian rhythms
to best capture
neuroplasticity--
that is the brain's ability
to change in response
to experience-- and in a way
that should allow you to get
one or two, or maybe even three
focused bouts of learning per
day, which can greatly
accelerate learning
of cognitive material,
languages, mathematics,
history--
for sake of school
or work, or maybe
just a hobby, or a personal
interest of some sort--
and for skill learning in
the physical domain as well.
Jackson then went on to ask--
you've mentioned
before that you try
to include at least one
90-minute focus block per day
as part of your work
and overall mission.
And indeed, that is true.
I tried to get at least one of
these focused ultradian rhythm
blocks per day.
That is a period
of about 90 minutes
where I'm focused on learning
something or doing something
that's cognitively hard,
although typically I
aim for two of these
sessions per day.
He then goes on to ask-- what
is the maximum number of blocks
you can perform sustainably?
The answer to that
is probably four.
And I say probably because
some people have schedules,
lifestyles, in which
four 90-minute blocks
of focused learning
is possible per day,
but that's highly unusual.
For most people, it's going to
be one or two, maybe three--
four, I would place in the
really extraordinary end
of things, maybe if
you're cramming for exams
or you've managed to go on a
writing retreat or a learning
and retreat of some sort where
you can devote essentially,
all of your non-sleeping,
non-eating time to learning.
But most people simply can't
organize their life that way.
So the short answer is--
for me, it's one or two
per day is the target
and three would be the maximum.
You then went on to ask--
do you take vacations
or extended breaks from these
ultradian rhythm sessions?
And the short answer is no.
Typically, I try and do this
every day-- and yes, even
on the weekends.
But on the weekend,
the ultradian rhythm
focused learning
bout might just be
reading a book for
about 90 minutes
or so, which might not be as
cognitively difficult as it
is for other sorts of work
that I perform during the week.
I occasionally
miss a day entirely
for whatever reason--
travel, obligations
related to family, et cetera.
But in general, I try
and do this every day.
I do think that the
circuits for focus are,
I guess the non-biological way
to put it would be kept warm.
But essentially, that accessing
the circuits for focus
is made easier by
accessing them regularly
and that's because
the circuits for focus
are indeed themselves
amenable to neuroplasticity.
In other words, the more
you force yourself to focus,
the easier focusing gets.
I'll now answer the last
part of the question
and then I will go through
and emphasize some tools
that anyone can use in order
to leverage ultradian rhythms
toward learning bouts--
either cognitive learning
or physical skill learning,
or a combination of the two.
The last part of the
question Jackson asked
was-- if you knew you needed
to drastically increase
the amount of focus you do
daily, how would you schedule
that focus and recover from it?
That's an excellent
aspect to this question.
And I will now give
you the details
of how I would use and
schedule ultradian rhythms.
I'll offer you a tool--
I've never talked about this
tool in the Huberman Lab
podcast.
And I will dispel a common myth
about ultradian rhythms that
points to a, believe it or
not, an easier way to leverage
them for maximum benefit.
OK.
So as I mentioned before,
ultradian rhythms are
these 90-minute cycles that
we go through from the time
that we are born
until the time we die.
Indeed, even during
sleep, we are
experiencing and
more or less governed
by these ultradian rhythms.
This question and this answer
is not so much about sleep.
But just know that when you
go to sleep at night until you
wake up in the morning,
every 90 minutes or so,
your patterns of sleep-- that is
the percentage or ratio rather
of slow wave sleep to light
sleep to rapid eye movement
sleep changes in a way such
that each 90-minute cycle gates
the next cycle.
It flips on switch for
the next 90-minute cycle
then that 90-minute
cycle ends, flips
on switch for the next one,
and so on and so forth.
I mentioned all that
because during the daytime,
the same thing is true.
But most people don't know
when the 90-minute all trading
cycles begin.
Because if you
think about it, you
could wake up on the
basis of an alarm clock
or noise in the room, or
simply because you naturally
wake up in the middle of an
ultradian 90-minute cycle.
So does that mean, for instance,
that if you wake up 60 minutes
into an ultradian cycle
that the next 30 minutes
of your waking--
right, because that
60 minutes needs
to continue to 90 to
complete an ultradian
cycle-- that the next
30 minutes after waking
are related to the
ultradian cycle
that you were still in
during sleep, or does
it start a new ultradian cycle.
And the answer is the former.
That ultradian cycle
continues even if you wake up
in the middle of it.
And so a lot of people who want
to leverage ultradian cycles
for learning will say, "Well,
how do I know when to start?
When does it start,
when I hit my stopwatch?
Can I just set a clock
and work for 90 minutes?"
And the short answer is no.
And that might seem
unfortunate, but the good news
is that you can figure out when
your first proper ultradian
cycle of the day begins simply
by asking yourself when are
you most alert after waking.
That is if you were, say
to wake up at 7:00 AM
and let's say that's the end of
an ultradian cycle or perhaps
you're in the middle
of an ultradian cycle--
doesn't matter.
What you need to watch
for or pay attention to
for a day or so
is when you start
to experience your greatest
state of mental alertness
in the morning.
And here, we can discard with
all the issues and variables
around caffeine or no caffeine,
hydrating or no hydrating.
Exercise is one variable that
we'll consider in a moment.
But here's the deal--
these all trading in cycles
are actually triggered
by fluctuations in the so-called
glucocorticoid system--
the system that regulates
cortisol release.
And as some of you have
probably heard me say before--
cortisol, even though it's often
discussed as a terrible thing,
it's chronic stress, cortisol,
cortisol, et cetera-- cortisol
is essential for
health and every day we
get a rise in cortisol in the
morning that is associated
with enhanced immune function,
enhanced alertness, enhanced
ability to focus,
so on and so forth.
In fact, the protocol
that I'm always
beating the drum
about that people
should get sunlight
in their eyes
as close to waking as possible--
that actually enhances
or increases the peak
level of cortisol that's
experienced early in the day.
And that sets in motion a number
of these ultradian cycles.
So for instance, if
you wake up at 7:00 AM
and you find that for the
first hour after waking,
you tend to be a
little bit groggy,
or you happen to be
groggy on a given day,
but then you notice that your
attention and alertness starts
to peak somewhere around
9:30 AM or 10:00 AM,
you can be pretty sure
that, that first ultradian
cycle for learning is going
to be optimal to start
at about 9:30 or 10:00 AM.
How can I say about if it's
indeed a 90-minute cycle?
Well, this is really where
the underlying neurobiology
in these ultradian cycles
converge to give you
a specific protocol.
The changes in cortisol that
occur throughout the day
involve--
yes, a big peak early
in the day if you're
getting your sunlight and
caffeine and maybe even some
exercise early in the day.
But typically, that
peak comes early.
And then across the day the
baseline jitters a little bit,
it comes down, but it
bounces around a little bit.
It's not a flat line,
if we were to measure
your glucocorticoid levels.
Each one of those little
bumps corresponds to a shift
in these ultradian cycles.
So if you find that you
are most alert at 9:30
or starting to
become alert at 9:30,
and then typically you have a
peak of focus and concentration
around 10:00 AM, that is
really valuable to know.
Because the way that
the molecules that
control neuroplasticity--
that is the changes in neurons
and other cell types
in the brain that
allow your nervous system
to learn and literally
for new connections to
form between neurons, which
is basically the
basis of learning--
those fluctuate according
to these ultradian cycles.
What does this mean?
This means if your peak
in alertness and focus
and energy--
could even be experienced
as physical energy occurs
at about 9:30 AM, I would start
your first ultradian cycle
for learning somewhere
around there.
Certainly 9:30 AM
would be ideal,
but 10:00 AM would
be fine as well.
And then you have
about one hour to get
the maximum amount
of learning in even
within that alternating cycle.
This is where there's a
lot of confusion out there,
people think, oh, ultradian
cycles are 90 minutes,
therefore, we should be
in our peak level of focus
throughout that 90 minutes.
In reality, most people
take about 10 or 15 minutes
to break into a really
deep trench of focus
and then periodically
throughout the next hour,
they'll pop out
of that focus, now
have to deliberately refocus.
This is why, if
possible, you want
to turn off Wi-Fi
connections and put
your phone in the other
room or turn it off.
If.
You do need your
phone or Wi-Fi, just
be aware of how
distracting those things
can be to getting into
a deep trench of focus.
But the point is this--
these 90-minute cycles
occur periodically
throughout the day,
but there is going
to be one period
early in the day--
and here, I'm referring
to the spirit of starting
at about 9:30 or 10:00
AM-- and then likely
another one in the mid to late
afternoon that are going to be
ideal for focused learning.
And that focus learning
bout should ideally
have you set your clock--
a stopwatch or something--
to measure 90 minutes, but do
assume that there's going to
be some jitter at the front end
where you're not going
to be able to focus
as deeply as you would like.
Then you'll get about
an hour of deep focus
and then you really
start to transition out
of these ultradian cycles.
How do when the afternoon
ultradian cycle occurs?
Well, just as in the
morning, it occurs
because there's a brief,
but significant increase
in the glucocorticoid system
in the mid to late afternoon.
I wish I could tell you
it's going to be 2 PM
or it's going to be 3:00
PM-- that's really going
to depend on the individual.
When you ingest caffeine,
some of the other
demands of your day.
But you can learn
to recognize when
these two periods for
optimized learning
will occur and here
are the key principles.
Watch for a day or two--
meaning pay attention
to when you have your peak
levels of physical and mental
energy in the morning-- that
is between waking and noon,
and then again between noon
and about 6:00 or 7:00 PM.
Although I'm sure that there
are some late shifted folks that
will experience their peak in
focus somewhere around 6:00
or 7:00 PM, especially
if they're waking up
around 10:00 or 11:00 AM, as I
know some people out there are.
Once you know where
those peaks in focus
occur on your schedule,
set a stopwatch
for one ultradian cycle in
the early part of the day.
In this example,
I was saying 9:30,
but if you can't hop on
it until 10, that's fine.
Set it for 90 minutes,
consider that block wholly--
meaning rule out all
other distractions.
But assume that within
that 90-minute block,
you are only going to be
able to focus intensely
for about one hour.
And just know that the molecules
that control neuroplasticity--
and these things have names.
And yes, Brain Derived
Neurotrophic Factor or BDNF
is the most famous of those,
but there are others as well.
In fact, the very
receptors that control
synaptic strength, the
connections between neurons,
some of the neurotransmitters
and modulators involved
in synaptic plasticity,
they undergo regulation
by these ultradian
changes in glucocorticoid.
And then try and capture
a second ultradian
learning block in the afternoon.
Again, just knowing that
the first 10 or 15 minutes,
consider it mental
warm up, and then you
get about an hour-- it's not
exactly 60 minutes, but about
an hour to maximize learning.
So if you're trying
to learn something,
really capture it during
that phase as well.
Now, is there a
third opportunity
or a fourth opportunity?
This relates to Jackson's
question directly.
And the short answer
is not really,
unless you're somebody who
requires very little sleep.
Within the 12 or
16 hours that one
tends to be awake during
the day or 18 hours
that one tends to be awake,
there are really only two
of these major peaks in the
glucocorticoid system that
trigger the onset of
the circadian cycles.
Again, there's a ramping
up and a ramping down
of glucocorticoids
throughout the day.
But the real key
here is to learn
when you tend to be
most focused based
on your regular sleep,
wake cycle, caffeine
intake, exercise, et cetera.
And again, that's going to
vary from person to person.
And you really only have two
opportunities or two ultradian
cycles to capture in order
to get the maximum focus
challenging work done a.k.a.
learning.
So for somebody
that wants to learn
an immense amount of material
or who has the opportunity
to capture another
ultradian cycle,
the other time where that tends
to occur is also early days.
So some people by
waking up early
and using stimulants like
caffeine and hydration
or some brief
high-intensity exercise,
can trigger that cortisol
pulse to shift a little bit
earlier so that they can
capture a morning work
block that occurs
somewhere, let's
say between 6:00 and 7:30 AM.
So let's think about
our typical person--
at least in my example that's
waking up around 7:00 AM.
And then I said, has their first
ultradian work cycle really
flip on because that bump in
cortisol around 9:30 or 10:00
AM.
If that person were say to set
their alarm clock for 5:30 AM,
then get up, get some artificial
light-- if the sun isn't out,
turn on bright or
artificial lights,
or if the sun happens to
be up that time of year,
get some sunlight in your eyes.
But irrespective
of sunlight, were
to get a little bit of
brief high intensity
exercise maybe 10 or 15 minutes
of skipping rope or even
just Jumping Jacks or go
out for a brief jog, what
happens then is the cortisol
pulse starts to shift earlier.
And so the next day
and the following day
and so on and so forth--
provided they're still doing
that exercise first thing and
ideally getting some light
in their eyes as well--
well then they
have an opportunity
to capture an increase
in cortisol that
is now shifted from about
7:00 AM to about 8:30 AM.
So they can capture
an hour of work there
and then they will also
still be within that rising
phase of cortisol
in the 9:30 to 10:00
AM block that lasts
until about 11:30 or so.
They might have lunch.
Perhaps after lunch, they
do a Non-Sleep Deep Rest--
maybe they, don't maybe you're
a napper or maybe you're not--
doesn't really matter.
And then in the afternoon--
and I would suspect
it would now be
in the earlier afternoon
sometime around 2:00 or 2:30
would be typical.
Although again, that exact time
will vary person to person.
Then they would want to schedule
another 90-minute work block.
So that's how you
can capture three.
Now you can start
to see also why
capturing four
ultradian work blocks
would be exceedingly rare.
It's just not typical
that people are awake
for that much of the day, you
have to sleep at some point.
And I should mention that if
you're going to force yourself
to wake up earlier on
a consistent basis,
you probably should be
trying to get to sleep
a little bit earlier as well.
Because it's not
just the quality,
but the duration of
quality sleep that really
matters for learning.
And I should also
remind everybody
that the actual
rewiring of neurons
does not occur during
any focused work block,
it actually occurs during
deep sleep the following night
and the following night, and
during Non-Sleep Deep Rest.
This is why Non-Sleep
Deep Rest can accelerate
learning because it's
in states of rest
that the actual
connections between neurons
strengthen or weaken
or new neurons
are added in a way that allows
for what we call learning.
OK.
So one or two all trading work
blocks per day is typical,
three would be
really exceptional,
and four would be extraordinary.
Look for them-- meaning look to
see when you are feeling most
focused and alert
typically in the period
before waking and
noon and typically
in the period between
noon and bedtime,
given your standard intake
of caffeine and exercise
and other life events.
Please also remember
that even though it's
an ultradian
90-minute work block,
the neuroplasticity is
going to be best triggered
within a 60-minute
portion of that.
And there's no way to
know exactly when that 60
minutes begins and
ends until you actually
begin the work block.
So this is really
designed to be empirical,
you need to actually go do this.
What you'll notice
again is that it's
hard to focus at
first then you'll
drop into a state of focus.
You may get distracted,
that's perfectly normal.
You refocus, get
back into triggering
learning-- that's really
what you're doing,
you're triggering learning--
and then there'll be some taper
and then you'll be out of
the ultradian work block.
Now, it's also a
key to understand
that myself and other
people should not
expect that they're only working
during these 90-minute work
blocks.
It's just that a lot of the
sorts of demands of our day,
including cooking and shopping
for groceries, and email,
and text messaging, and social
media-- a lot of those things
don't require intense
focus of the sort
that I believe Jackson is
asking about maximizing,
and that I'm referring to when I
talk about these ultradian work
blocks.
And then as a final
point, I've been
talking about these ultradian
work blocks and focus,
et cetera, in a context
that brings to mind ideas
about cognitive work.
So learning a language,
learning math, writing,
or creating, doing something
related to music, et cetera.
But these 90-minute
ultradian work blocks
also directly relate to
physical skill learning as well
and to physical
exercise as well.
So if you are somebody who's
really interested in improving
your fitness and
your fitness requires
a lot of focused attention--
so for instance, when I go
out for a long run on Sundays,
which is part of
my fitness routine,
I deliberately not
thinking about much,
I'm just trying to cruise along.
I might focus a
little bit on my pace
in stride, maybe an audiobook
I'm listening to or a podcast.
But typically, I'm
just cruising along,
it's low cognitive demand work.
These ultradian work
blocks can really
be maximized for
pure cognitive work--
book type work, et cetera,
music, et cetera, or they
can also be leveraged
toward skill learning.
So if you're trying
to learn how to dance
or how to perform a
particular athletic move
or you're trying to get better
at some skill that requires
a lot of focus and alignment of
muscular movement and cognitive
demands, et cetera,
well then these
are also going to be ideal
for triggering neuroplasticity
to get better in the motor skill
based domain as it's called,
et cetera.
If you'd like to learn
more about ultradian
shifts in neuroplasticity
and ultradian work bouts,
I will certainly do more on this
in the standard Huberman Lab
podcast.
But the key words
to look up if you
want to explore this
further online--
it's not something that
a lot of people about,
it's called iterative
metaplasticity.
It's a vast literature
and one that I'd
be happy to teach you in a
standard podcast episode.
But in the interest of getting
to more questions from you
all, hopefully the
answer I've given
you now has been complete
enough, yet clear enough,
and yet succinct enough
that you can start
to leverage these
really powerful aspects
of iterative metaplasticity and
ultradian rhythms for learning.
And I'd just like to point
out that these opportunities
for focused learning that occur
in these 90-minute ultradian
cycles are really
terrific opportunities.
They are offered to you
at least twice every day
and you can really learn
to detect when they occur
and when they're
likely to occur.
You can certainly learn at other
times in the 24-hour cycle.
But for anyone who's tried to
stay up late at night cramming
for an exam or
for somebody who's
tried to learn during
the sleepiest time
of their afternoon, we can be
very familiar with the fact
that there are times of day in
which we are best at learning.
And as I've just
described, there
are ways to capture
those moments
and they are valuable moments.
So even though it's just
about three hours per day
or really only two hours
per day because of the 60
to 90-minute thing that I talked
about a few minutes ago, learn
to know when these occur and
really treat them as valuable,
maybe even wholly in the sense
that they are really the times
that are offered
up to you each day
by your own biology in ways
that will allow you to get
better pretty much at anything.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions, plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel--
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast.
And to fund research--
in particular,
research done on human beings.
So not animal models,
but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is the species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels.
Not just the premium channel,
but through all channels--
Huberman Lab podcast and
other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the research that
provides those kinds of answers
in the first place.
Now an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do a dollar
for dollar match
on all funds raised for research
through the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again there's a cost
of $10 per month
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs
you can ask questions and
get answers to your questions
and you'll of course get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast episodes
and not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]